the first movie I remember seeing that
really affected me and kind of made me
want to jump into this thing and make
movies is probably the the movie and the
shot that I think more people will point
to as that one thing that did it which
is of course the opening shot of star
wars with that that ship going over the
camera I remember that that shot in that
movie had an impact on me but it was
really about five days later my mother
bought me this making of book and I
actually have it right here and you can
see it's got some of my original artwork
at it from a little kid but there's this
photo in it of the miniature of that
ship and I saw this photo and thought
how did they get this thing for feet
long how did they get that thing to be
that thing that seemed like it flew over
the camera forever and whatever that
illusion was that you could ply to
either blowing models up or creating a
story from scratch or a character from
scratch I just as a little kid even
before I know what about cameras or
lights or acting or any that kind of
stuff I just was really attracted to
sort of inventing stuff from scratch
that seemed that would seem real to
other people when it was finished